It's time to play Circus Folk.
Circus Folk.
(cheering)
Big money. Big money.
Last week was
the 56th anniversary
of the debut
of The Family Circus.
-Yeah, that's right.
-(laughter)
Oh...
Uh, this is not a...
it's not...
I wouldn't call it a...
a-a funny comic strip.
It's sort of a, "Oh, I'm gonna
send that to my Aunt Mavis"
kind of a comic strip.
It's an infuriatingly saccharin
little bubble of family values
that's been a tumor
on our nation's funny pages
since the Eisenhower
Administration!
Just take a look
at this (bleep) drivel!
"What do birds do
if they are afraid of flying?"
God...!
(laughter)
-(whooping, applause)
-(exasperated grunt)
Why was that published?!
This is (bleep), like,
the monologue in Ted Cruz's head
most of the time.
(laughter, whooping, applause)
Thankfully, the Tumblr
Time is a Flat Circle
has had some fun
with the captions.
Uh, "What happened to my head
is not something
that gets better."
(laughter)
-I feel it.
-Well, we wanted to...
we wanted to get in
on the action as well,
so, comedians, I'm gonna show
you a Family Circus cartoon
that we've removed
the joke from--
and I mean loosely, "joke"--
and for 250 points,
I want you to give me a new line
for this precious little moment.
All right, first up,
this tender scene.
What's going on there, Jesse?
Uh, it's a rectal thermometer?
Now you tell me!
(laughter)
-(whooping, applause)
-Yep.
Ron.
Uh, Mom, you can use
my vaporizer,
but you got to use
your own weed.
-All right, points.
-(laughter, applause)
(cheering, whooping)
Next up, this family outing.
-Jesse. -Jesus Christ, Dad,
I think you killed that guy.
You're not even
gonna go back and check?
-(laughter, whooping, applause)
-Points.
Tom.
(high-pitched): Is there gonna
be pizza at Mom's funeral?
(laughter)
(applause)
-Ron.
-Son, hand me my gun.
Dilbert's cut us off
for the last time.
-(laughter, applause, cheering)
-Points. Yep.
Next up,
this adorable little exchange.
Ron.
Hey, look, lady, you pay
for the dick, not the height.
(laughter, cheering)
(applause, whooping)
HARDWICK:
Yes.
(cheering, whistling)
We... It's unfortunate
we just can't hack the site
and put things like that
on there.
Tom.
That's not
a Fugazi T-shirt, bitch.
Fugazi doesn't sell T-shirts.
-(laughter, cheering, applause)
-MAN: Yeah!
One guy got very excited
about that.
-Next up...
-You and me, guy.
...this imaginative scene.
This imaginative scene.
Tom.
I got my third callback
for Goosebumps 2.
Jesus, who do I got to blow
to be in Goosebumps 2?
All right, points.
I think that would
probably be R.L. Stine.
-I would imagine.
-Really?
And pretty easily done.
-Next up...
-Two phone calls.
Next up... Two...
Why two phone calls?
Is this the exchange?
Yes, get me R.L. Stine.
Hello, this is R.L. Stine.
Why, hello there, I guess
this was one call, wasn't it?
Hello?
You're up, I'm on my way over.